hi my name is Dylan Valesky I work for a
wool firm in the dish resistance
Department mostly I'm projects like the
cloud today my talk is on building
automated analytics platforms using
Wolfram technology specifically focusing
on automation and ingestion
visualization and distribution of Alex
I'm Dylan Pulaski I'm a software
engineering
Wolfram's distributed system it's
engineering department mostly working
products like cloud and private cloud as
well as doing a few other things and I'm
here today to talk about design the
implementation of an automated analysis
and reporting system which is hopefully
a very long title for something that's
relatively simple and straightforward to
do so what I'm here to talk about today
is kind of the automation aspect of data
science so for the most part a lot of
talks that I see either talked about it
trying to ingest the raw data and import
it and maybe do some cleaning or it's on
the other end where it's okay you have
data in like a data set and you just
want to do visualizations and make a
pretty one-off report but a lot of times
in real life you're gonna be doing that
same process over and over and over
again every day every week every month
and it'd be nice to be able to build an
automated way of just having a system
that goes out gathers the data that you
need does all the cleaning the
pre-processing that you need to stores
that somewhere does any analysis that
you need generates the visualizations
and then distributes it to whoever or
well whoever or wherever it needs to be
viewed so I'm gonna be talking about
building one of those systems like one I
built for Wolfram's in-house public
relations department which handled going
out gathering media mentions for terms
like Mathematica and well from language
storing all that doing analysis things
like sentiment analysis you location
analysis time series stuff and building
reports for the PR department to
actually be able to get a better idea on
where we're being talked about without
having to manually go out on the web and
read every news article so that line is
gonna be something like this I'm going
to talk about the design for the system
itself since most of the tasks well all
the tasks are automated I'm going to
talk about the structure that I use for
designing those tasks specifically and
then go into a little bit of detail on
the PR department specific application
in how its data collection works how the
cleaning processing task works some data
visualization and statistics examples
and then how to actually build those
into reports dashboards
and publish and share all that data so
the system itself is relatively small
and straightforward so I have a few
different tasks there's a data
collection tasks this one actually goes
out calls the api's that provide the raw
data from web crawling imports it in
does some minimal cleaning on it mostly
trimming out fields that I know we don't
need for analysis or that are just
excessive handles any missing data at
that point and then stores it in an MX
file the next task is the cleaning and
pre-processing stage this one will
actually read in that raw data handles
actually computing things so taking
strings converting them to data objects
taking raw text doing sentiment analysis
on it actually doing kind of the heavy
lifting for getting ready to generate
visualizations and again then once it's
finished with all that analysis dumps
out the data in a nice data set to an MX
file to again be written later the stage
after that is the visualization and
presentation phase so this is where the
actual individual graphics will be
generated so things like date histograms
or geo bubble charts or just general
histograms or any kind of table showing
raw data and a little bit nicer and more
consumable format so things like this is
the title of the article here's a link
here's a quick emoji that shows what the
sentiment was for it so I had a glance
someone that doesn't know anything about
computer science could still look at it
and understand what's going on and then
the final stage is taking all those
visualizations pulling them together
generating a single unified report that
can then either be hosted on the web or
emailed out to individual well employees
that need to see it or again this stage
is the more custom stage because it's
the how do you actually want your
results to be consumed but I'll go
through a few different scenarios and
how to handle that so as far as the task
design goes I'm using scheduled tasks to
pull it on the Wolfram public cloud in
this case I try to make the tasks
relatively small themselves so generally
any code
i factor out into a single Wolfram
language package deploy that to the
cloud and then my task will get that
package call some function from it pass
in any configuration files that might
specify things like what term was
searched for or what specific type of
analysis needs to be done you give that
task a schedule on the public cloud
tasks are limited to run once per hour
so in this case I'm specifying hourly
and then finally I set the notification
function option to the list of admins on
the system the idea here being if this
hask fails for some reason maybe the
internet goes down on whatever node this
is running or something else goes wrong
only the people that actually could fix
the problem get notified rather than
anyone that consumes the report or the
one employee that set this up ten years
ago but has little since left the
company this way people can more easily
get access to it now there's a few
different reasons why I break the tasks
down into a package with a small amount
of task code here as well as a different
object for a list of admins mostly this
comes down to redeploying the task so if
you embed all your code inside the task
then any time you need to make a change
whether that's adding a new field to be
analyzed or trying to adjust
I don't know plot themes on a specific
visualization you'd have to redeploy the
entire task this way you only have to
redeploy the package if the code changes
if you wanted to change the schedule
then all you need to do is change the
schedule for the task if you want to
change the list of admins you only have
to update the admin object it's kind of
segmenting the code to avoid well if you
say wanted to change just Alisa admins
having to remember the full code for the
scheduled tasks or where that code lives
to redeploy it now actually getting to
some data sciency stuff so for the PR
department platform I built we use a
third party API system called web hose
that goes out and actually crawls the
internet for all the data given that
today is Halloween I thought my live
data example would be searching for all
articles on the internet continuing the
word Halloween I'm limiting it to only
web sites ranked under 5,000 this will
thin down the amount of data I get so
that hopefully the computer doesn't blow
up while I run it do the basic
pre-processing and produce an decent
data set by the end so ya get a days
that looks something like this this is
kind of what the raw data looks like so
it's not thinned down at all none of the
data has been interpreted interpreted to
any kind of extent you can kind of see
raw URLs everywhere you see really ugly
uu IDs to identify articles this is that
kind of first step the reason why I
break up this step from the
pre-processing step is with a lot of
api's especially ones that crawl the web
looking for articles that could
conceivably be in a lot of different
languages things can go wrong when
trying to do that interpretation maybe I
get something that has I don't know
emojis in it and I didn't account for
that when trying to do my sentiment
analysis I might want to preserve that
raw data for future analysis and details
later so get the raw data save that
worst case I end up deleting it best
case maybe I can reuse that for some
more advanced analysis later on as I say
next is the Kinane processing stage so
this is where I go through and start
actually dealing with the data first
filter it down to just the fields that I
care about in this case it's dealing
with things like the title for the
article what site category it was listed
under discussion blog news
country codes they're built in spam
score in performance score some social
analysis so where things were liked and
shared nothing too crazy
next I build a bunch of interpreters to
interpret into the final fields I want
so timestamp does some work converting
things into data objects properly taking
into account time zones things like text
I don't want to I con this because it's
a massive function that deals with
trying to determine the sentiment
assuming that the language for the text
is actually English in our built-in
classifier can handle it well and also
looking for emojis because that might
wait things in different directions the
country handles converting things to
actual geo entities based off of what
they were listed as which
seems straightforward until I realized
they didn't list European countries all
the time sometimes they only listed EU
so being able to deal with both those
cases and then some of the things like
scores it also does some more
classifiers and more analysis so
initialize those functions and then
finally this also sorts the articles by
the time stamp so that everything's
already sorted and pretty once it gets
that step and now it's going to take
time because to contact ball from
servers at this stage does anyone have
any questions about things covered yeah
for the most part a lot of times I am
using the built-in interpreters
sometimes I want to do something a
little bit more specific to my own
application in which case I might change
it so for like data object because the
interpreter has to deal with ambiguity a
lot of times we're dealing with like did
they put it year month day or year your
date month since I know that it's a
consistent format I can skip that step
and just say this is the format this is
how you read it in and parse the string
for a lot of things like language yeh
detects English correctly because it's
just as English and handles it perfectly
well so some of these functions really
are short so let's open the language one
so yeah the language interpreter if it
lets me scroll to the right well if it
let you scroll to the right all it says
is interpreter of language of the
specific column that contains it so it's
a bit of a mix of both it really depends
on the specific applications on which
ones I intend to use so once you
actually have all that data analyzed and
in the format that you really want it in
now you can actually have fun and
generate visualizations for that so at
this stage it's kind of dealing with
writing the actual visualizations you
may want or that you think you might
want playing around with things and
coming up with the exact code generates
those in this case I was going to do a
date histogram but it looks like the
kernels crashed so we'll just keep going
but the idea would be it shows the data
been by ten-minute slots for all
articles in the past it was 95 elements
so probably about past 6 hours
of data once you actually have those
visualization tasks up and running you
have to decide on how you actually want
to have the analysis consumed sometimes
it might just be you already have a
dashboard webpage up and running that
shows a bunch of analysis and you want
to augment that to show more information
in that case just having a task that
exports all that data to a PNG file so
you have a nice visualization to look at
it could also be something where because
of your system the data is can be
updating fairly regularly instead in the
scheduled tasks you can use a delayed
object and again have it be referenced
as a PNG even cache it if you want and
we'll see an example of that later if on
the other hand maybe it's you're trying
to replace a report that you want that
you have to send out every single day
showing I don't know mentions of your
company on Twitter or something along
those lines you can use with quarter
document generator which is a subtype of
scheduled task scheduler tasks are just
execute this code on this schedule what
document generators do is they take a
template notebook and potentially driver
details for that notebook and regenerate
well basically called generate document
on that template on that schedule so if
you wanted to say have a full notebook
with interactivity that's just being
regenerated every hour on the cloud you
can easily deploy using a document
generator
additionally there are options like
delivery function which allow you to
send that report as an attachment to an
email to whatever users you want and you
can also specify down to okay for these
five users send it as a notebook because
they have Mathematica for these 15 users
send it as a PDF because they don't need
to interactivity and then maybe they
don't have a site license or you could
send it just as well a PDF to whoever
you want really it can also just be a
raw function so if you want to if the
output shows this send it to these
people if it shows something else don't
send it to them because it's probably
wrong and send it to a third party and
the notification function for document
generators behaves the same as it does
for scheduled tasks basically
say who you want to be notified when it
fails who you want to be notified when
it succeeds if anyone or who do you want
to notify just that it ran successfully
or not again we can also be a raw
function so you can get kind of creative
with how that exactly works the other
example that I was talking about was
using Adelaide in this case the idea is
I want to have a web page that contains
maybe some more HTML based things so not
just images but maybe it generates a
table maybe it generates I don't know
series of buttons or links that you can
click but you have an XML template or an
HTML template that you can use XML
template to apply and again whatever
template code you want you put in here
whatever computed values you want to
pass in whether those are actually raw
data or links to the cloud objects that
contain images you can put provide is
the second argument as an association
next you specify that you want to be
HTML if you know that that's only going
to be updated every hour you can add
cash persistence option and specify that
you want a cash to stick around for an
hour what this means is rather than
wasting computational time regenerating
these images every single hour when no
one's looking at them so overnight you
can use a delayed where it will only
update if the cash is over this cash
persistence value so if it's 1:00 in the
afternoon and someone looks at it and
someone looks it again at 110 it's still
gonna be the same cash but if someone
looks at it at 5:00 p.m. and then the
next person doesn't look at it until 8
a.m. there was no recompute ated data in
between it just stayed quiet
it doesn't recompute until the person
that a.m. actually decides to look at it
one thing to note at this stage is
because it is only recomputing on the
man with the cash expires it's not
cached when it needs to be regenerated
so it will be slightly slower business
to recompute everything so if you say no
that at 10 a.m. you're going to have a
meeting with the CEO and he's going to
be upset if the network seems really
slow because it has to recompute a
thousand images maybe have a scheduled
task or something that calls that URL
and generates the cash for you right
before the meeting
I don't want to say I knew that from
experience but I know that from
experience additionally if you do want
to have that kind of full interactivity
experience that you would get with a
notebook but maybe you want it kind of
inside of another website or another
dashboard that you already have as
Steven mentioned during his keynote
address and as a few other developers
have talked about during their talks
there is the wolfram notebook and better
library so you can still have your
report generated as an actual notebook
on the cloud and then just embed it in
whatever website or dashboard you're
currently using lastly there is a QR
code that if you want to scan on this
page to see an example of a delayed
notebook
that's using some actual generated data
that I did earlier today feel free to
scan it at this point it's all hosted on
a public cloud and should be public to
everyone so if you have trouble seeing
it let me know and I can quickly get on
our cloud and change things yes the
notebooks unpassable and then there's a
link on the very last slide to a full
github repository that includes both
this notebook as well as all the code
that I used for the media monitoring
system that I built for Wolfram so if
you feel like monitoring your own media
mentions for free so the kind of last
and biggest kind of discussion point is
publishing and sharing of all this we've
talked about distributing it through
either emails or having web pages up
there but we haven't talked about kind
of gatekeeping on those web pages at all
so there's a few different systems
within Wolfram's cloud to handle
permissions if you say have a group of
users so like a team that you always
want to be able to view a specific
report or even edit it you can use
permissions groups to set up that group
of users and be able to handle emailing
all reports to that group or just giving
them permissions to be able to view a
specific object additionally there's a
function called permissions key which I
guess the closest analogy would be it's
a password protection on a specific
document so if you say only when people
that you've given the password to you to
be able to view it but you're kind of
happy to give that password out to
anyone that needs to permissions key
work
personally for reports I prefer groups
over keys just because groups change and
I don't feel like trying to have to look
up a password to send out to different
people beyond both of those if you kind
of don't care who sees it or you want to
everyone to see it you can also just use
the cloud publish function to make any
reports public for everyone so that's
kind of what I did with the previous
example notebook it's public so any of
you can view it I don't have to deal
with keeping track of users I don't even
have to keep track of whether or not the
users authenticated I get Church to
collect credits for it anyone can see it
and then if you want to dive deeper into
the permissions system and have more
finicky settings on who can view edit or
do anything with a given system there's
always the set permissions option for a
given cloud object so if say you have a
report that runs every week it's only
kind of viewable to your group but maybe
it's towards the end a year it's a
really big report it shows that you guys
have been doing great and you want to
share that with the CEO you can modify
the permissions on that given instance
so they can see that one but not have
any clue that all the other ones have
been existing so as I said the last
slide QR code to the github repository
where all of this is listed there's also
as Steven pointed out during his keynote
badge for the repository since there's
only one notebook which is this
presentation in that repository at the
moment it will automatically open that
this slideshow on the Wolfram cloud so
you guys can view it and scroll through
and hopefully reevaluate my code and
have it work instead of have the
computer crash but yeah so um any
questions
[Applause]